madam president the majority as consent
the quorum call be suspended without
objection madam president has been a
great source of debate over the past
couple years over a very basic question
how was jeffrey epstein able to take his
own life in federal prison on august 10
2019
last week we found some answers in the
new york times
it pointed out a series of stunning
failures within the bureau prisons
according to the times i quote the newly
obtained records offer no support to the
explosion of conspiracy theories that mr
epstein's death was not a suicide
but they do paint a picture of
incompetence and sloppiness
by within by someone within the bureau
prisons
that incompetence and sloppiness was
evident from the moment jeffrey epstein
entered the metropolitan correctional
center
on his intake sweeping screening form mr
epstein was described as quote a black
male close quote with no prior record of
sex offense convictions
a five-second
google search
would tell you that not only was jeffrey
epstein white
he was one of the most notorious sex
traffickers in recent history and what
about the night he died he'd already
attempted suicide in the weeks leading
up to his death so you would think that
the officials in the bureau prisons
would keep a close watch over this
potentially suicidal inmate in fact the
opposite happened
jeffrey epstein was left alone
unmonitored in a cell
the two officers on duty were allegedly
dozing off and scrolling on their phones
and the next morning epstein was found
dead with a bed sheet tied around his
neck
because of these failures the survivors
of epstein's despicable crimes we'll
never get to see him brought to justice
six months after epstein died former
attorney general bill barr
hand-picked michael carvajal to lead the
bureau of prisons
it could have been a new beginning for
the bureau a chance to get to the bottom
of widely publicized neglect and
mismanagement and to hold the
appropriate parties accountable but that
fresh start never came because since day
one director carvajal of bureau of
prisons has shown no intention of
reforming that institution
consider the case of the warden who ran
the metropolitan correctional center the
night jeffrey epstein died
how did director carvajal respond to
that warden's failure of leadership
well if you can imagine it he actually
rewarded him
director carvajal appointed the same
warden to lead a different facility the
largest federal prison in the united
states
fci fort dixon new jersey and it seems
that warden hasn't learned any lessons
in leadership since mr epstein's death
just last month an inmate in fci fort
dix was attacked from behind and stabbed
in the eye
these are not isolated incidents for
years the bureau of prisons has been
plagued by corruption
chronic understaffing and misconduct by
high-ranking officials in the nearly two
years since director carvajal took
control of the bureau he has failed to
address the mounting crises in our
nation's federal prison system it is far
past time for new reform-minded
leadership in the bureau of prisons
a few weeks ago the associated press
published a breathtaking investigation
into the bureau they concluded that it
is quote a hotbed of abuse
graft and corruption
and has turned a blind eye to employees
accused of misconduct
since 2019 madam president more than 100
federal prison workers have been
arrested for
charged with or convicted of crimes
including sexual abuse murder
and introducing contraband into prison
altogether these crimes account for
two-thirds of the criminal cases against
all department of justice personnel even
though bop employees comprise less than
a third of the workforce i want to share
a few of the stories from the associated
press report
at one federal prison in mississippi an
official responsible for investigating
the misconduct of other staff members
was arrested for his own misconduct he
was not only accused of stalking and
harassing his fellow employees
but he was allowed to remain in his
position
he was even authorized to continue
investigating one of his accusers
in california a warden of a federal
prison women's prison was arrested and
indicted earlier this year for molesting
an inmate
they even kept lewd photos of the victim
on his government-issued cell phone
he allegedly told the woman that she
shouldn't even try to report the assault
because he was quote close friends with
the official who would investigate it
the list goes on it's a recurring
pattern of misconduct by officials
within the bureau of prisons who believe
that they can abuse inmates and break
the law with impunities in some cases
that's exactly what they've done
the details in the ap investigation are
shocking
and for those of us who've been
following director carmel hall's tenure
they are the latest disturbing examples
of failed leadership
time and again he has categorically
failed to uphold his chief
responsibility as director and what is
that responsibility protecting the
health and safety of inmates and
correctional officers today the bureau
suffers from chronic and significant
understaffing director carvajal has
failed to contain outbreaks of covet 19
which has led to tens of thousands of
inmates and staff contracting the virus
and when it comes to reforming our
federal prison system he's failed
in 2018 congressional democrats and
republicans came together on an
overwhelming bipartisan basis to enact
the first step act it was an historic
piece of reform legislation to create
new pathways for prison inmates to
better themselves while they serve their
time so they could return to society
once released nearly three years later
the bureau president still hasn't
implemented most of these reforms one
example under the first step act
low-risk inmates are eligible to earn
time credits reducing their sentences
they do this by completing programs
designed to prevent them from committing
another crime
last month the inspector general at the
department found that the bureau of
prisons has not applied these earned
time credits to any of the approximately
60 000 eligible inmates
now the senate judiciary committee which
i chair is charged with overseeing the
bureau of prisons we've tried to get
answers from dr from director carvajal
and his team
we've repeatedly requested information
we've asked for details about the inmate
banking system now there's a heck of a
story
purportedly has little oversight by the
bureau of prison has allowed inmates to
avoid paying child support restitution
to crime victims
other obligations the bureau reportedly
allowed larry nasser
the so-called doctor who abused hundreds
of young gymnasts before he was
sentenced to life in prison to spend
thousands of dollars from his bureau
presence account on himself
but pay only three hundred dollars
toward the debt he owes his victims
the bureau has delayed responding to our
questions or just flat out ignored him
it's past time to replace director
carvajal this can't wait any longer the
associated press's revelation shows us
that lives are literally at stake i know
attorney general garland understands the
urgency i'm calling on him today to move
immediately to dismiss director carvajal
and to bring real reform to direct to
the bureau of prisons madam president i
yield the floor
you